(audience applauds)
It is time for Drew's News,
Your daily, "bleep, blorp, bloop" from the good news robot.
(Ross laughs)
I can't do the robot.
You know, who does the robot the best?
Leonardo DiCaprio.
Really?
The words of Paris Hilton, "So hot".
Well with me at the desk is the hottest man in town,
also my co-pilot, Ross Matthews.
(audience applauds)
Bleep, blop, blorp.
Hi, everybody.
(upbeat music)
First up in the news,
we're starting with the latest fashion trend.
This is so fun.
The New York Post says that people are showing off
their bagel pride with "delicore".
God, it never stops, you guys.
Local bagel shops are pumping out custom merch
so you can rep your favorite local deli in style.
Here's some examples.
Pete Davidson is on trend here with Uncle Paulie's,
the hat he is wearing, that's a deli in LA.
And then, fellow hottie, Jake Gyllenhaal
teamed up with Russ & Daughters for a limited lox sweatshirt
and then Coach and Zabars got together,
and they had a bagel bag, baby, retailing at $550,
which sounds like a lot of money, but it sold out.
Yeah.
You know, it's not a lot of money for a bagel bag
but it is a lot of dough.
(both laugh)
(audience laughs)
Thank you.
So stupid.
But I love that this wearing your bagel pride
is now a trend.
Do you know how long I've been doing it?
Like this is a bagel, this is a bagel, this is a bagel.
I've been wearing it for years.
That's where I was going with it too.
Next up, everyone loves to get a taste of Texas,
including wonderful Prince Harry.
People reports that he was recently spotted in Fort Worth.
Wow.
That's right,
we love Fort Worth, attending his very first rodeo.
He went to the Stockyard Championship,
and one coach said it was the first Prince
he'd ever seen at the rodeo.
Now Chip and Jo, you're Texas royalty.
Have you ever been told that you kind of sort of
have some similarities-
Ah.
With a Harry and a Meghan?
Is there some symmetry there?
I love this comparison for sure.
Right?
I don't like picturing him
at a, you know,
he went from Buckingham Palace to Bucking Bronco.
Can you imagine?
(Chip laughs)
Well, like, him in a rodeo, like
"Giddy up horsey, giddy up".
That's the thing, I can see them anywhere now,
because they're going everywhere-
Yeah, love that.
And they're living their dream,
and they broke out and I'm just like,
they're the living example of don't stay stuck.
Well, we've gotta take a moment to celebrate
the life and work of an incredible woman.
CNN reports, Betty Reed Soskin,
the oldest ranger in the National Park Service.
Well, she just retired, Rossy, at the age of 100.
Wow.
That's right.
Betty worked at a park in Richmond, California,
that is dedicated to highlighting the works
of Americans on the home front during World War II,
and Betty was one of those women.
After facing discrimination in the Air Force,
she went on to work for the Boilermakers Auxiliary Union.
Yeah, and Betty's work shed light
on the diverse group of Americans who supported the war,
but often went unnoticed in the history books.
And you can hear Betty's entire story in her own words
online and the info's on our website.
Congratulations Betty.
(audience applauds)
And thank you for your incredible service.
100 years.
Like that is an extraordinary life.
We've got a beautiful moment
from Oak Hill elementary school, in Georgia.
The head custodian there, Lana Gazhenko is a Ukrainian
with a family living back home in Ukraine
and USA today reports that the students at the school
wanted to show her that they were thinking about Miss Lana,
so they put up this surprise art project,
and it's dozens of hand drawn sunflowers,
the national flower of Ukraine.
And messages, hoping for peace and safety
from Miss Lana's family and all of Ukraine.
(audience react emotionally)
I know.
(audience applauds)
Right?
Yeah.
I don't think that needs any words.
(bright music)